this is what unpopular looks like
president lukashenko may be determined
to hold on to power
but he knows the people aren't with him
he had a bird's eye view from his
helicopter but it doesn't seem like he
cares
[Music]
there they are fleeing like rats he said
in video distributed by his presidential
press service
these huge numbers speak for themselves
though the calls for lukashenko to leave
reverberating around the capital and
across the country
[Applause]
i think that everyone here on the square
is afraid and there is a reason to be
scared
because our government has already shown
how it can treat its people
but there is faith more faith and fear
so that's why we came here today
we are here with all the girls to show
that we are against violence lies
and unlawfulness authorities should not
be like this
the last number some brought photos of
the awful bruisings inflicted on some of
those who'd been detained
and reenacted the scenes of torture the
nation has had to reckon with
no counter demo today despite an uptick
in rallies in support of the regime this
past week
with the green and red bella russian
flag symbol of lukashenko's 26-year rule
increasingly on today is show
by the red and white of the protest
movement it is also crawling
with security forces and police with the
army standing by
president lukashenko has said that the
people have this weekend
to consider but that as of monday in his
words power
must be power
in other words a proclamation that the
government will exert its authority
using
whatever means it chooses the march for
a new belarus as it was called headed
towards the presidential palace
but turned round those careful to keep
the peace not prepared to engage with
those with a reputation for violence
the show of strength from the riot
police echoed by their president
in video he clearly wants his people to
see
stepping out of his helicopter as the
demonstrators dispersed
dressed in full riot gear and carrying
an assault rifle
thanking his security forces for the job
that they do
to rapturous applause
the last dictator in europe proving why
the title has stuck
dynamic sky news minsk